- [Man Voiceover] We have
been called the Indians.
We are the Halluci Nation.
(electronic tribal music)
- [Narrator] Tribal music, club music
mixed together and made by these guys.
- [Man Voiceover] I'm DJ NDN.
- [Man Voiceover] I'm 2oolman.
- [Man Voiceover] I'm Bear Witness
and we are A Tribe Called Red.
- We remix traditional pow wow music
with contemporary club music.
- [Narrator] First nations pow wow music
originated in the North American Plains.
Traditionally it consists of a large drum
with singers and dancers around it.
- Essentially, pow wow music's
traditional dance music.
That's why we ended up doing what we do.
We're using our music now
in much the same way
that pow wow was used,
to create a gathering place.
- [Narrator] And to A Tribe Called Red
pow wow music isn't just an adopted style.
It's a significant part of their heritage.
- I'm Anishinaabe from
Nipissing First Nations.
I grew up around pow wows
and going to pow wows.
They're big cultural gatherings.
- The significance of us
using pow wow in our music
is just a way to create something
that represents Indigenous people
and that Indigenous people can relate to.
(cheering)
(electronic tribal music)
- [Narrator] Their shows are
a cultural fusion experience
combining more than just sound
but visuals too.
- We ended up hooking up with some people
who were doing the same thing
we were doing with dance.
They're a Native dance crew.
They're breakers.
But they mix it with pow wow.
So it's that same kind of fusion.
- [Narrator] And it's that combination
of contemporary and tradition
that's introducing Indigenous culture
to a wider audience.
- I think when we started
if you asked your average
non-Indigenous person
in Canada
that if they had known
what pow wow music was
they would shrug and say, "No".
Now, I think that's begun to change.
(electronic tribal music)